Net neutrality suffers
a blow in the courts,
but is this the end for
free and open internet?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, this is Annie
filling in for DNews.
On Tuesday, a US
Court of Appeals
ruled against the Federal
Communications Commission
in a decision that voided
much of the FCC's existing
net neutrality rules.
The ruling was the
result of a suit filed
by Verizon who charged that the
FCC's neutrality rules violated
their First and Fifth
Amendment rights.
Those rules, which the
FCC put in place in 2010,
dictate a few things.
Basically ISPs
can't discriminate
against certain
types of traffic,
can't block any lawful
content, and should
be open and transparent
with customers
with how they manage
their traffic.
But in this decision, the
court rejected those rules
on the grounds that,
quote, "The commission
failed to establish that the
anti-discrimination and anti
blocking rules do
not impose, per se,
common carrier obligations."
Common carriage
is a legal concept
that informs the regulation of
traditional telecom companies.
In 2002, though,
the FCC classified
ISPs as information
services rather than
telecoms, which weakened the
relevance of common carrier
principles as a
framework in this case.
What does this all mean though?
Basically, this decision would
allow broadband providers
much more freedom in
creating new pricing
models for internet,
and to strike deals
with internet companies
or content providers
deliver their content
more readily to consumers.
We don't know yet how
a ruling like this
would shake out in deals among
the ISPs, internet companies,
and content providers, and then
trickle down to us consumers,
but one possible scenario
is tiered internet service
where ISPs could charge
more to companies
like Netflix or Google to
deliver their traffic faster.
Together, just those two
companies make up over half
of all internet
traffic, according
to one study by the
firm Sandvine in 2013.
But advocates for net neutrality
say that pricing environment
will hamper innovation,
in effect killing
the current open atmosphere,
where anyone with an idea
can build it online at
relatively low cost.
And more broadly, some are
worried that the decision could
give broadband companies
too much power in deciding
what content is
freely available.
I don't think too
many of us are in love
with the idea of Verizon
choosing what we can see,
but does this mean that
net neutrality is dead?
Not exactly.
FCC chairman Tom Wheeler
pointed out in a blog post
that the court's decision
did concede that the FCC has
the authority and
the responsibility
to regulate the activities
of broadband networks.
In other words,
the court rejected
the framework
offered by the FCC,
but not the idea that they can
regulate internet providers.
Someone just has to come
up with a better framework
for regulating the uncharted
territory that is the internet.
And the FCC says
they might appeal
the ruling, in which
case it could end up
in the Supreme Court.
But either way, the battle isn't
over, so let us know your take.
Will this decision
be bad for consumers?
As always, you can
weigh in with us
on Twitter or Facebook,
@DNews, and you
can ping me as well, @AnnieGaus.
Thanks for watching.